[Music]
Sicario day of the Soldado so this is
Sicario to the sequel to Sicario you
remember Zakaria stars Josh Brolin
Benicio del Toro Emily Blunt essentially
hunt cartel - the name of the game same
cast this time except Emily Blunt she's
not in it and in this movie the
government gets his bright idea to start
a cartel war among cartel that's the
mission goal at least one of the plots
of those movies not gonna lie I feel
like a theme of Sicario 2 is for Sicario
to change into another Sicario film to
have like sequels among sequels that are
inside this one sequence like the
inception of Sicario but for a large
chunk of this movie I was locked in I
dug the Misha Josh Brolin Benicio del
Toro that crush it as always Rowland's
having a summer man this is like 2018 is
the age of Brolin also there's a little
girl that comes into the movie I think
she was really good she was great in
fact I felt like this story involving
her could have it could have come to
fruition a bit more and that's one of
the gripes in this movie as much as I
was really digging it for the first half
the movie then becomes something else
cool I'm down with a flip but then
there's this other side plot involving
this kid he's kind of working with the
cartel I feel like this movie just
didn't know what it wanted to bate when
it's exciting it's exciting what its
intense its intense attention buildings
never as good as his predecessor sure I
was enjoying this movie as a good sequel
with a slight case of sequel itis that
is when a sequel is not as good as the
first but in the long run by the time
this movie wrapped up I really felt like
this movie had a case of identity crisis
I feel like it is me jumping to
conclusions I have nothing back in this
up but I feel like what's happening with
Sicario when dealing with Sicario one
two Sicario to what we saw happened with
the Pirates of the Caribbean films and
the matrix just on a much smaller scale
or the first movie was made and it was
supposed to be one movie a sequel is not
needed and someone at some level was
like a sequel needs to happen I think
what was made for some chatter granted
the job of any movie is to make money
for the studio but sometimes you just
wish with a movie like this you want the
characters to come first you want the
passion of storytelling to come first I
didn't feel that here in fact this movie
feels like it was three different
scripts that were crushed together it's
like there now we have one movie in fact
we have a Sicario sequel in a world word
the Devils in the details this is one
part it's just it just kind of baffled
me it's gonna be a nitpick it's not like
a game breaking things out like I saw it
I was like well you know what now it's
over no there's this one scene where a
car hits another car and there was this
big shootout on the street
in a city's like happening on the
sidewalk and every car passing the shoot
I was just kind of going like no car
screeched the brakes when the shootout
started no cars tried to make a u-turn
after the firefight no cars that were
coming just hauled ass to get out of
there at no point in production when
this firefights going down no one was
like excuse me shouldn't the cars on the
road just react just bystanders going by
a shooting because it's more then by the
last act of this movie maybe the last
quarter of this movie I felt like no one
knew how this movie was supposed to wrap
up then it just it wrapped up even
including one part where the Sicario
films to this point felt like they were
kind of wrapped in reality just felt
very grounded I don't know I can't
qualify that I'm not the foremost mind
on cartel hunting I know nothing about
it but you don't have to be to see that
these movies are grounded in the grit of
realism and something happens you're
like yep Hollywood and the movie ends
living you kind of unfulfilled this has
happened to me a lot lately where I
don't hate a movie but it's so much
easier to talk about the negatives than
it is the positive Sicario 2 was quite
enjoyable for the first half of the
movie maybe the first two-thirds of the
movie it is a bit unfocused in its
execution but I do like some of the
twists and turns they did take it asks
you to take a couple of leaps to even
believe what happened could happen I
didn't know is by that what we have is a
sequel that's enjoyable enough but in
the end it's a sequel that didn't need
to happen nor do I think it's a sequel
that was planned to happen it feels like
a reactionary sequel I'll say you can
enjoy it but it might be a better time
if you're drunk ya know it's a party
well bum me out is for so long in this
movie I was like I'm enjoying it and I
would have said it's a good time no
alcohol required but the way certain
things just wrap up in the end just felt
sloppy like they were out of ideas and
they just had to end it it was supposed
to be a three hour long movie that was
sliced down to two don't know right so
Sicario - have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]